bullets hit an ice immigration
enforcement office in San Antonio
earlier this morning
now federal officials say it was a
targeted attack on the building fox
chief breaking news correspondent trace
Gallagher has more on that trace Martin
shooting happened overnight at a nice
facility in San Antonio nobody was hit
by gunfire but officials say there were
employees working at the time and they
were narrowly missed and several windows
were broken the FBI says the location of
the gunshots is no accident watch all of
the shots that we have found are on the
floors where ice had offices so this is
no question a very targeted attack it's
not a secret facility you can go online
it's a public it's out there so they did
some research they knew what floors ice
was on they knew what buildings they
were in and they they hit those one
person was detained for questioning but
released and while investigators review
surveillance video there is ongoing
concern over the potential for future
attacks with ice saying quote political
rhetoric and misinformation that various
politicians media outlets and activist
groups recklessly disseminate to the
American people regarding the ice
mission only serve to further encourage
these violent acts this comes one month
after a 68 year old man with a rifle
attacted Detention Center operated by
ice in Tacoma Washington tossing
incendiary devices at cars and trying to
blow up a propane tank that I said could
have resulted in the quote mass murder
of staff and detainees the man was shot
and killed by responding officers and
left behind a manifesto where he
identified as an Tifa and called
detention centers concentration camps
so the demonization of ice seems to be
having consequences thank you for that
trace